hello and welcome to the shaky science
show so I said to myself that I wasn't
going to do another video on the
coronavirus because mainly reading all
the news pretty much terrified me but as
a scientist I'm very much interested in
the ways that we're currently developing
different treatments in terms of
reducing the transmission but also in
terms of trying to find ways of dealing
with people who've already been infected
and trying to you know reduce the number
of deaths that we we are seeing and
there is some interesting research out
there already and I will discuss one
company access that may have a potential
treatment for the acute respiratory
distress syndrome that we've been seeing
associated with cave 19 so firstly just
a bit of background about offices so
it's a biotechnology company and the
main focus of the company is on
regenerative medicine so regenerative
medicine it's just a field of biology
and it covers the process of replacing
engineering or regenerating human cells
tissues or organs in order to restore or
establish a normal function of it back
tissue so the product that arthas's is
developing is a stem cell product
referred to as multi stem so stem cells
an easy way to think of them I just
cells that can continuously divide or
they have the capability to also a
differentiate which means they could
turn into specialized cells such as a
skin cell so the origin of this product
that offices of developing is from
healthy adult adult bone marrow tissue
and so they take these cells and then
they can expand them outside of the
human and when I say expand I just mean
that they the cells can divide and the
important thing is that no genetic
manipulation for cards any cells they're
exactly the same as what they were taken
from the adult and then these cells can
be produced they can replicate and then
they can be frozen down for one that
actually needed but they're really
really cool thing about this technology
is that whereas most like treatments you
offer
a transplant that requires a blood for a
tissue type match the thing with multi
stem is that it doesn't need this and
say it's more widely available to people
and the second really cool thing about
it is that the delivery is I guess
somewhat semi invasive because you could
do it intravenously so if we take a look
at offices offices I know if we look at
that website you can see that they're
doing a variety of different clinical
trials for 40 different disorders so
some of them are neurological such as
strokes but the one I guess of interest
at the moment is the acute respiratory
distress syndrome and so before this
novel coronavirus outbreak even a cards
they had already done a clinical trial
using this multi stand therapy for odds
it's probably easier for me just to say
odds on that one and so if you actually
go onto the website this little video
here is actually really good like
probably better on this video but in all
seriousness odds is the most frequent
cause of death following Cabot 19
infection and so it just happens because
when the virus in fact said infects the
lungs and the lungs then become inflamed
and this inflammation can accumulate
fluids and this is referred to as a demo
but when this happens the lung tissue
becomes structurally abnormal and so the
lungs can't function as they would
normally and oxygen intake into the
bloodstream and to your tissues suffers
so the big problem at the moment is that
there is no fda-approved and effective
medicine for ARDS and the current
standard care is to just place the
patients on a fence later which forces
oxygen into the lungs to keep the
patient alive but unfortunately this
isn't fully effective and obviously
requires the availability of ventilators
so given the success that
ethicist saw with their clinical trial
for the treatment of odds they've now
been given an fda fast-track to pursue
this father for the treatment of capered
19 and I went going to any more detail
than that because I actually came across
so recent
while actually it came out today on Fox
News I was an interview with the CEO he
actually can
being probably better than I can so you
I'll put the link down in the
description but I thought this was worth
talking about since I haven't really
seen that prop up too many times in the
knees at the moment and given there's
also been some crazy changes in their
stock price I just thought be
interesting to talk about it say Oh be
well only time can really tell to see if
the treatment will be effective but
nonetheless the multi stem therapy that
they put established here is really cool
and definitely has potential for many
things in the future anyway so as always
hopefully you've learned something and
thanks for listening